french police escorted salah abdeslam to
paris's high court for the start of the
trial into the 2015 paris attacks
wearing a black t-shirt his hair long
abduslam sat with 13 of his co-accused
in a specially built courtroom abduslam
is believed to be the only surviving
attacker he fled the city after the
killings four months later he was
arrested in brussels
when a judge asked him to confirm his
identity abdeslam said
first i want to testify that there is no
other god than allah and muhammad is his
messenger the judge replied we'll talk
about that later abduslam went on to say
that he had given up work to fight for
isil
it was nearly six years ago that 10
attackers rampaged across paris killing
people in cafes the bataclan concert
hall and outside france's national
sports stadium by the end of the night
130 people were dead isil claimed
responsibility the french president
declared a state of emergency across
france there was shock and grief
hundreds of people are expected to
testify at the trial that's scheduled to
last nine months for the relatives of
the victims and survivors it is likely
to be an emotional and harrowing ordeal
we first met muhammad amgar a few months
after the attacks he was working outside
the stadium when an attacker blew
himself up muhammad was badly injured
now he says he wanted to be in the court
to see the accused they look like
they're afraid you know they're afraid
to be healed they look like they lost
are you scared to come here a scale of
what
i don't think i can be scared because
for me like i said long time ago each
day is extra day for me
other victims though decided to stay
away
index
the suffering is unspeakable it is
inexpressible what they expect is for
justice to be particularly firm
the acts of which the defendants accuse
the particularly monstrous acts
abduslam has so far refused to cooperate
with french police he may choose not to
testify during the trial
some hope that he will break his silence
and shed more light on what happened and
why either way after so many years most
victims hope that justice will finally
be served natasha butler al jazeera
paris